alors à propos d'écriture beaucoup
parler vous écrivez ceci une écriture
graphique le mot pour le mot le mot
véhiculant l'idée non pas l'idée
véhiculant le mot primordial j'écrivais
des chansons parce que simplement des
mots vous amènera les idées n'ont parlé
à l inverse sous aucun prétexte que je
ne veux 20 de réflexe malheureux ou 1 4
1 qui troue le cul du chante du brut
des vents et qu'est ce que vous voyez
qu'il se sont nés et maux qui minent et
non pas les lui mine de lâcher je suis
persuadé que là que des chanteurs qui
sont à ma gauche là ne sont pas d'accord
la mort à bombay chacun sa manière des
handicapés demandant la parole oui vous
êtes d'accord l'appui qu'ils veulent
dire c'est ça qui doit énerver des gens
mais j'aurais jamais moi je sais que
j'aurai jamais chanté s'il existe jamais
fait jusque vers les a déjà dit de la
musique avant toute chose il déroule les
verront ils étaient à sa table là bas
l'autre quart gainsbourg non mais c'est
idiot cents contre vous il ya un petit
contentieux l'ain je vends parce qu'une
chouette
non mais je connais pas ce nid d espions
chinois ben isa et sandra nieri mon
avenir mon nez troupe ensuite ensuite
quand quand on compose et la guitare
et quand on commence bien quand on a
fait des années de bien bas commence à
la guitare
mais ça passe
et souvent seigneur s'est nourrie bob
dylan à compassion composaient la
guitare grâce à la guitare ou dit gosper
la guitare à ces lignes en bas